so this is the beginnings of the
business offices will come back and tour
this this got redone a couple years 20
years in this piece so I run own phone
flexes digital yes well this produces
radio show greetings
textures welcome to the number one show
in hip hop brought to you by the
birthplace of hip hop hot 97 facts I'm
Jesse K this is my co-host tat wizza aka
the hip hop tech wizard was good be
today we've got the ultimate hustler in
digital period he's got his hands in
everything behind the scenes but is
quickly becoming the face of business
tech mr. Gary Vaynerchuk good dude I'm
good guys thank you so much for having
me oh thank you for coming
what a year 2006 to the best Gary you
fell off everybody's like this the worst
year I can't wait for this year to be
over I love this year yeah it's been a
great year for you I'm talking about
it's always a greater if you're alive
it's a great year you could decide it's
a bad year but there's not the best
business year I've ever had but it's the
best year because what's the alternative
I love your energy I appreciate it so
many times I'm out here telling people
like yo um you know get up pull your
bootstraps get up here get out and do
something with yourself because there's
no limit its you to stopping yourself
and I see that in your messages all the
time to me I always get an extra bolt
when I'm around hip-hop and urban demo
because they understand it better like
it's unbelievable how much I in my brain
and a there's a forewarning all of you
are about to say you know it's
unbelievable how much in my brain I
think that my son white kid Upper
Eastside rich is that disadvantage over
minority from Harlem if that kid if she
or he understood what eating dirt how
much of an advantage that actually is I
lived it I came from nothing so I he I
wish they knew and so every time I'm in
a setting like this versus a you know
I'm in a suit which is you guys know
everybody's making jokes they twice a
year funeral and I had to be at the New
York Stock Exchange today like it's
unbelievable to me how much people don't
get it and realize how much
opportunities and when you come from
zero you have an advantage in 2017
that's not a disadvantage and I'm trying
to get people through sheer will and
putting out content to understand that
fact you first got on my radar when you
were one of your company's Wine Library
TV wasn't hopping on YouTube yep and you
came out with this rant talking about
the entrepreneurial spirit of tech being
very like the early days in hip hop and
I remember that this guy is one of us
you know he's he's talking hip-hop and
tech at the same time but that was like
eight years ago
2008 I made a video 2009 I made a video
that said Tech is about to be what
hip-hop 85 was you know I grew up in
Jersey and Edison so you know I'm I'm
cliche white kid that was affected by yo
MTV raps part of that first generation
adidas note you know time you know
that's what I grew up in a lot of
diversity back then and so you know I
remember when I thought the fat boys are
Beastie Boys or Kerris when were famous
but I knew that the world did it and and
now the biggest rappers in the world are
the most famous right yeah and so that's
what I saw in tech when Kevin Rose and
zux and and sokka and EV Williams are
like okay I know they're gonna be big
and they're cool but the world doesn't
yet I remember telling Kevin Rose who
was the founder of digg.com which was
the big site back in the day I said you
need to understand that we're gonna be
like the baseball players from the 50s
and 60s where they made less money in
their Hulk Willie Mays like made less
money in his whole career than an
average baseball player makes in a year
now but one of the legends in the game
and so I said the Kevin I said you're
gonna be a legend in the game cuz he was
a web 2.0 legend I said but you need to
understand one thing the next you in
seven years is gonna be dating
supermodels and we were mate I was
making that joke and sure enough you
know Evan Spiegel married a super
models so I think it's uh you're right
that was the video where I first kind of
like put that out there and I'm
impressed that you sniffed out that what
I was up to that's how you got on my
radar you've been steady grinding ever
since now and prior it feels like this
year though with maybe the rise of
snapchat and maybe your content engine
heating up that you've really kind of
become a household name in this space
yeah this was the very big year for me
like if you look even at basic vanity
numbers of growth of like my social
numbers between d-roc and I getting
serious you know yesterday or day before
was the one-year anniversary of dailyvee
the document the thing that I do you
know we got we got serious I got to a
place where vaynermedia for a lot of you
that don't know I have a company that
does social media advertising and
digital advertising for the biggest
brands in the world it got big enough
where I could afford me being the face
of it to put some dollars into people
against my brand and yeah this year
everything changed
in in a pretty significant way so I
first saw you and forgive me for just
catching up but I worry a little back to
this point most people are just catching
up a little less than a year ago right
after CES my first episode dailyvee zero
zero threes a friend of mine from
Silicon Valley said hey you remind me of
somebody I want you to check out Gary
Vee yeah so I watched this episode while
driving in my car and you said something
that just took me I was like you are
this is the guy it's about to get crazy
honestly in a different way
you said dj khaled was the ashlynn
Kushner for snapchat me what a sand
krishna was to Twitter
yes introducing it to people and just
how it was to snapchat and I knew like
County is a really good friend of mine
I'll even say and I'll put this out
there right before Khaled exploded on
snapchat he was in New York and we were
snapchatting in the studio he was here
he he had just popped the term major key
yeah mid flex with hot 97 yep and we
were using snapchat and he went back and
figured out how do you snapchat for him
and became the king a hundred percent me
so when I saw you say that I was like
does this guy you knew that I knew right
because it was still early that was
still that was January 5th yes you know
Khaled really popped I mean I'm really
in my [ __ ] you know that can I curse on
this of course okay go to November 13 16
that's when his stuff really started
getting going so he's six weeks in but
cuz I was there for with Ashton and I
was there I was like okay this is the
guy and this is the platform and by the
way I've been pressuring back to music
back to all your homies
somebody's gonna be that for musically
there still isn't a mainstream celebrity
that just decided to oh and it's so
crazy musically such a thing to win for
a musician because you could win the
entire 11 to 16 year old girl ecosystem
yeah and I'm just like yelling at some
of my famous music friends like do this
do this so Khaled was the guy that
figured I had a story tell on a platform
that was about to become mainstream
Ashton did that on Twitter and
somebody's gonna do that musically and
then the house party or something else
or something that's gonna be a method
next year there's always gonna be a
Christopher Columbus and I know you're
tight with him
big economics are crazy the amount of
money Callens Macon's [ __ ] knowing
how hard he's worked I'm also I pay
attention of the grind the spinning
night after night the grind and he
doesn't fly the grind grind to think
about the endorsement deals and the
bizdev deals and the money that's being
pumped into his world it's a lesson for
everybody listening as you know and this
isn't just for people that have calots
Fame all the aspiring hip-hop artists
like pop where everybody actually
and then you got a shot so we're gonna
talk about 2017 this episode's gonna be
futurists you have talked what's coming
next
starting with CES where Kat just first
learned about you last year what do you
see for 2017 CES how does that set the
time you know it's funny especially
because I know a lot of people just be
learning about me right now
I'm not Nostradamus right like I love
people that think I am but I'm not and
so the answer is I'm not sure I'll tell
you what I'm paying attention to right
now there's three after school you know
for high school kids house party I
already mentioned it Marco Polo there's
things that are popping
but anchor and Peach and you know Yik
yak there's always been these things
there's nothing yet that is like 100
person I was paying attention to and
talking about snapchat for two and a
half years before I got loud you saw the
fat me in 2012 talking about like I was
I was like so there's nothing that is
like there's nothing at least right this
second that I would put my name on
saying 2017 s the year of I didn't know
that Instagram was gonna follow and copy
features from like you never know just
what I think I'm good at and what you've
probably seen the last decade is when I
taste it I'm like a shark with blood you
know sharks are crazy like a little like
a mile ago like a mile out like a like a
look a little speck of blood and like
that's what I'm good at
when I feel that when I taste that blood
in the water I'm so [ __ ] on it it's 24
I shut down in December on my family
vacation and spent every minute
dissecting snapchat cuz I knew Khaled
had popped they're like wait a minute if
Cal it's pop and this is really double
good for me because the way he rolls
that's kind of similar to like the way
we got our differences but like the
thing that the kids are attaching to
that motivation like I'm like I'm living
that right like for real
I only do that I don't ndj that is me
that is what I do and so I think that um
that's what I'm paying attention to I
don't know what's next but I'm always
circling those waters and don't let
somebody drop a little ounce of blood
because I'm going
24/7 at it once I taste it fact so dad
was leading into the next question right
I was going to ask you
snapchat or Instagram what do you do
both and we kind of figured you'd say
that so what do you do first both at the
same time yeah do you not you're not
going snapchat then taking that video
and putting it on Instagram honestly
that's just a cadence that's a moment in
time like that's a however you feel like
which one you like but anybody who's
listening right now that wants to make
something happen you're gonna build the
next biggest clothing line both right
you want to get some new customers for
your bakery shop both you want to get a
job interview at a social media shop
both like if you have ambition your
actions have to match that and too many
people are just like not putting in the
work their mouth is right ahead of their
[ __ ] reach you know actions like
really you're gonna be the greatest NBA
player of all time why cuz you think you
got a little handle on the weekends you
need to shoot 15,000 free throws before
school every day and so you know to me
to me the answer is both and it's not
even a foot like when people in business
like if you're a normal person if my
brother-in-law
Alex Klein is like what should I do for
my life I don't care one or the other
but if you're a business person or
you've ambitions or you want to run for
office or whatever you want to do both
always end use every and Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube and SoundCloud and
and and and do you think the spectacles
will help snapchat I do I think here's
here's my big macro POV on this snapchat
is the first social network that has a
chance to be a brand people think about
snapchat the way they think about Yeezys
the way they think about SoulCycle the
way they think about starbucks it's a
brand and that's what these glasses
these spectacles have a chance of doing
if they pop and they hold Wall Street
business people the people that roll
with me are not just gonna think and
compare it to Instagram and Facebook
they're gonna compare it to Instagram
and Facebook and Under Armor and that's
a place where they want to be because
then all of a sudden money goes up then
all of a sudden the company's worth more
money and so to me as a cup
that has IPO ambitions and wants to be
on the stock market next year that's a
big deal so saw that with the lines they
were crazy
yeah and they worked really well we love
them I'm super big into consumer gadgets
we have um so I think that they are what
Google glass should have been to
consumers but the reason they were is
Google and this is for everybody who's
listening this is a great segue and I'll
take it to a macro level this is about
knowing your DNA this is where you have
to know yourself let me explain
Google was started by two nerds mm-hmm
so when they made a consumer product it
was nerdy you ever seen the picture like
like if you're listening right now
Google Google glass like you don't want
to hang with that kid
snapchat snap made spec that's made by
Evan Spiegel he's dating a supermodel he
was a cool LA kid he went you know like
he's 25 like the way they rolled it out
the vending machines like it was a PR
play it was like marketing it's branding
it had a hell of a lot more Nike in it
than it had Apple right and even apples
crossed over and has that but like
snapshots at a whole different level and
so I mean straight up if snapchat is
successful with this at scale and every
16 to 26 year old is wearing them and is
into them and the real play is is
definitely gonna be Summer Jam &
Coachella and like when when the summer
comes around if East Coast kids are
wearing those glasses to their vacation
then they've got it and now all of a
sudden you got a debate are in the same
way that nobody thought that Nike would
get knocked off by Easy's like our snap
sneakers the hottest thing in 24 months
that's why this matters so much because
they're going into brand not just tech
platform and especially in the context
of the people that would listen to
something like this people that listen
to something like this they understand
flavor they understand swag and that's
not just about how good a product is and
that matters yeah can we talk a little
about Amazon and then we can talk about
anything you want my man echoes you got
me echo has been huge for the holidays I
love it cell I agree we're how does it
end the drone culture that Amazon's
Amazon's Amazon's a beast she things do
you think that the echo changes the game
and I sure do yeah easy
when you're brushing your teeth and
you're down to the last piece of your
toothpaste and you say Alexa reorder my
toothpaste
whoever Amazon made to deal with on the
other side is gonna sell you that
toothpaste and that is worth good
trillions
that's more than billions that's more
than trillions that's good trillions and
so for me it's huge
AI voice activation like here's the
thing that a lot of youngsters if you're
listening you're under 25 that you can't
know because this has always been your
life but old cats like me 40 like need
to understand right we just started like
does everybody understand what's going
on here we've just started technology's
not going backwards like all these
parents that don't want their kids and
iPads I want my kid an iPad 24/7 365 not
only do they learn faster what world do
you think they're gonna live in yeah
like one outside and play
you're giving them a disadvantage by
hundred hundred what do you think your
kids are gonna be doing so I think I
think voice AI a are V are all that
stuff is coming I don't think it's at
scale I think Alexa is the first
consumer product that has scale so I
think a lot you know it's fun now it's
fun to walk in and be like you know put
on that chance album and they do that's
cool that's funny that's like we haven't
had that before but it's gonna get way
more serious than that
Alexa fill up my car with gas now of
sudden who's gonna invent the uber for
gas world you don't have to go to a
station but gas comes to you and the
reason you did that was because of Lexus
see how I'm thinking I didn't even think
it of course not that's why I'm the bet
I'm just gonna go Leslie on a very but
this sound brain thinks I think to chess
moves like I know what's in front of us
right but what's that I met my wife on
JD in 2003 if you went on internet
dating you were the biggest weirdest
nerd living in your mom's basement I
wasn't scared cuz I already played the
chess games and said everybody's gonna
do this got it yeah and so that's it
like that like that's what everybody
listening has to do if you want to make
money you pay attention if you want to
be rich you pay attention to what's
going on now
if you want to be wealthy like all time
wealthy you need to understand what's
gonna happen next after this and so we
need to understand what happens with
these norms and so I think alexe is a
big deal I think anybody who's lucky
enough to be able to afford that because
that's a luxury in their home and uses
it
we'll see how their behavior changes and
then what's gonna happen is the same
reason my five year old my four and a
half year old comes to a TV screen and
swipes it and is blown away by why it's
not doing something everybody listening
right now in six years is not gonna
accept things not being voice-activated
you're gonna text that way you're gonna
talk that way you're gonna order like
you're gonna I mean the headphones
listen the headphones are out now like I
don't have them yeah they're out and
about right like it's gonna be
voice-activated because all we care
about is speed and if I could say it
faster than I text it then I'm good yeah
yeah it's comfy really that's why
texting exploded it's faster than
talking yeah but if you're just walking
or if you're driving and you need to
pick up your kid or do the laundry if
you've got your ear pieces in and say
you know Siri order my laundry or you
know everybody's gonna have a basically
an assistant at their fingertips you're
never gonna forget anything anymore
you're gonna get everything done it's
gonna be unstoppable
with Google home coming into this space
too you can even ask Google Facebook
Apple Amazon these four or five six
seven biggest tech companies they're all
gonna be playing yeah they're all
competing against each other you know
there'll be a facebook home and a Google
home and an apple they're all gonna
fight for it yeah that Google just got
into the game with devices and their
whole different system together and and
I just think it's amazing it's great but
I've also been preaching caution like
okay yes you have to do this but you
have to do it you have to learn it the
best way and how it works for you so
you're not just out here giving away
your information or you're just not out
here doing it the wrong way and looking
like a fool I'm glad you're giving that
advice but when people ask me about that
stuff I'm like well let's talk about
alcohol yeah let me give you advice
don't drink 80 [ __ ] 40s you know like
in one night like you know what I mean
like everything in modern how long did
it take people to learn that though you
know you had prohibition where
everybody's pork to join anyway that was
religion oh yeah but I think you're
right and that's exactly right but the
other thing that you learn is
people are good in the last 15 years all
of us giving away our data doing all
this there wasn't as much bad right it's
no sure that everything's like this is
back to the opening line of this
interview things are good
you want to talk about and mainstream
media wants to talk about and people
want to talk about the small percentage
of bad yeah I'm thrilled and by the way
there's plenty of bad there's always
gonna be sexism and racism and religion
persecution there's always gonna be that
that's how humans roll nature but
anybody that wants to level this
conversation up with me at a macro level
it's better yes
1945 was not as good as today yeah if
you were alive ten years ago in
cognizant then you know the difference a
hundred percent yeah this is also a
great year for the music business its
spending up I love that it's great to
see that vinyl every aspect of music is
growing a lot of has to do the streaming
wars you know Spotify title Apple music
yep art which one are you leaning
towards which one do you got music as a
place where I don't like to talk a lot
about because I think one of the great
things that have happened to me in the
last four years is I don't talk about
[ __ ] I don't know and it's made me real
popular people pay attention because you
know what I talk no reason to time when
I'm talking about MA you want to talk
about Alexa you want to about Facebook
you want to buy Instagram I will bring
up bring anybody here put sucks in here
bring them all you want talk about music
there's a lot of people that understand
it better than I do
I've always historically stayed away
from music because of all the legalities
and things of that nature and it made it
scary for me look it's tough to bet
against Apple because when you have all
the money in the world sitting in your
bank account you could buy Spotify in
title 44 times over right so that's one
thing that I think about to actually
give you an answer not stay away from it
I you know it's funny I never thought
music was in trouble I thought the music
business that was built where people
that were taking too much of the cut was
in trouble and that's good I like that
I want the artists to have more leverage
artists have more leverage today than
ever because distribution has been
commoditized the games changed so you go
through it 10 20 year period where it's
scary people cry but on the other side
of it it's better and so I'm you know of
course
music to me music is always great you
know why it's one of the four or five
cultural pillars of society it will
always be here people will always care
about music people always care about
sports people always care about religion
people always care about sex
they're like only a couple of things
that people always care about music's
one of them music crosses over all even
all those boundaries some people might
not like sports some people might not be
religion segregates your passion is what
you're into it's it's one of the things
that's what he's saying if you're
passionate about music then you're
diving all in but you may be passionate
about sports or whatever the case is and
you've worked passionate about tech yeah
and you've always been a music fan
obviously but I'm a funny fan like I'm
not as educate you know it's funny that
Boyd here like when Boyd became AJ's
friend and college I was like okay cool
some kid that really knows hip-hop and
I'll really be on top of it early like I
loved music for escapism so the reason I
like hip-hop as a person is far more
because I like storytelling like I'll
give you a good one I don't really give
a [ __ ] about beats all that much like
the melodies like the heart like I like
the story like biggie won me because he
told a story yeah like I need
storytelling like I understand like I
don't when I was in the Kendrick Lamar I
don't love like the music I don't need
to like listen to it 50 times don't
wanna know who produced it I'm very
aware of how important how other people
only go with producing and only the
music I need the story I need the lyrics
and the words and what does it mean and
where is she or he going and so but what
music does for me is when I go on you
know a flight like Sabah right I'm all
about Sabah right now and so like I'll
listen to the same to Sabah from his
last thing you just dropped I'll listen
to the same two songs the whole six
hours to LA tomorrow that's what's gonna
happen so I know a lot of people
listening especially because it's hot
now he said like love music like all my
moves my friend moves at Mount Ida
college she was a real hip hop and put
me on to Scarface was super into the
Houston scene two to three years before
Master P and everybody started learning
the South he would only listen to a song
once and then cherish it he would
cherish it for like four weeks
I heard first of the month by Bone Thugs
and played it 47 thousand times in a row
so I know that I listen to music in a
way that hardcore music people don't
respect as much and I know that I get
that I love that I watch football
I'll watch football tonight that just
have a Monday night game of the someone
we're taping this and I'm gonna watch
offensive lineman's block technique I
know people don't watch football that
way so you know it's what you you know
music much like the other ones obviously
you some people go extremely deep and
really kind of know it but even me who's
not deep needs it it's a part of his
life and that's what I love about it we
should have a guy here named Ebro Ebro
in the morning he's also on beats one
yeah the big guy yeah he recently said
something that a snapchat was in trouble
now I kinda was wondering that as well
with Instagram doing what they did and
we asked about the spectacles I do think
that is going to because his views are
down on snapchat cuz everybody's views
are right right but my real question is
everybody's really talking about how
Twitter is in trouble could Twitter
become MySpace yes that's scary for
Twitter was scary for me too I'm gotten
used to getting my news from Twitter
great people used to get their news from
the radio fax fax right I was used to
getting my music from MTV so we just got
a real line and get our news from
snapchat or Instagram yep okay and by
the way Twitter is the reason I'm even
sitting here as you know Twitter was the
first time I really popped back in the
day I was doing my wine show I jumped on
Twitter I thought I was gonna be big it
was it happy and way bigger and and I
really popped and transitioned in the
business contents that a wine content
and so I love Twitter Twitter's like the
first girl I ever hooked up with you
know what I mean there's that always
that peace in my soul and so it makes
it's hard for me to say that by the way
I sit on a lot of Twitter stock I sold a
lot of it but I still have a lot I have
a lot of economics do they got a change
you got involved like Madonna did it
right she reinvented herself 14 times
that's why she had a long career you
know like you've got to reinvent
yourself uni praat Twitter didn't make
product changes for six years in its
prime yeah you know so I let's talk
about sports when you're the best
athlete and you're like the guy and
you're
like one top 15 players basketball
looking at dunk you know at Duncan in
Surrey I'll give you some love he's got
one of the big basketball counts so I'm
thinking about that I think about
basketball players draymond Green he's
my buddy Tremont really worked on his
game every offseason you know Ricky
Rubio the flashy point guard from
Minnesota if he developed his outside
shot he would have been a much bigger
player he had all the passing skills the
quickness he's got everything if instead
of going to Ibiza and [ __ ] chicks in
the offseason he worked on his 18-foot
jumper he'd be in the game
Twitter was banging chicks in the summer
got it yeah but their season algae
that's what happened and guess what and
then you deserve to lose cuz some other
kid isn't yeah some other kid is sitting
in the rain on July 16th taking 55,000
shots and that's what snapchat and
Instagram did and that's what happened
I'm not gonna lie that's why I respect
Mark Zuckerberg so much because he's the
best
you think he's letting something happen
and then even before they make change
his months back he buys Masquerade the
people that made the snapchat filters
and you're like oh they got some [ __ ]
coming and then he drop all this other
stuff
he hasn't even dropped that yet he's a
long-term player he's a beast he's thick
you know it's the same way I thought
about Hillary Clinton like when I was
like uh I would always say about Hillary
Clinton I was like yeah but Hillary will
go to Russia go to a meeting with Putin
slice his throat walk out Putin's dead
and Hillary and her and Hillary's like I
don't know
and I'm like [ __ ] I want that on my team
and that's how sucks is sucks doesn't
look the part like no nobody who's
listening or watching right now scared
of sucks I'm currently here gieux kid
walking in you're perfect he will kill
you yeah like when it comes to business
what he does he will kill you you oh you
copied my [ __ ] and yeah do something
about it uh-huh you want to talk about
real like you want to convey it into
hip-hop he rolled up on you in the
street punk you took your [ __ ] wallet
looked in your face and said do
something yeah that's what Instagram
just did
now it's evans call now evan either
doesn't do something and then that's how
it ends we all know that Maury does
we're about to find out
before Instagram did this they answered
everything so fast and he haven't
answered Instagram yet so I know they
got something because it's a 3-way
because it's different
snapchat was innovating yeah now
introducing so like it's a real battle
sucks have you know Kevin Systrom you're
talking about real winners this is a
real fight yeah
there's a real fight like you know this
isn't like oh you get like a rap battle
you're like this guy versus this guy
you're like ah you know like no this is
a good one yeah not everybody sure
what's gonna happen and the truth is
both are big enough to win so that's a
whole nother thing like everybody loves
you know when two artists get into a
battle who wins both oh yeah unless you
get completely punked home addresses in
a song he tried to kill 50 cent yeah but
he was good enough like that's what's so
great about business it's so similar to
hip-hop if you're good enough you will
stay yeah and if you're not you won't
like that's it so if makes good enough
he'll he'll stay maybe you didn't
respond fast enough maybe people that
aren't isn't deep into it as you are
think it's still over cuz that's the
real issue with fee thing but I I think
that's right and that's and that's how I
think about it and so like when I talk
about three four years ago liking Bezos
and sucks more than Steve Jobs people
got mad at me because he was such a
pedestal but to me like they're the next
generation entrepreneurs and both of
them have had monster 3 for years and I
don't and that's not gonna go away
because if you're good you're good you
touched on something right a eyes and a
show just finished Westworld did you see
Westworld no but I know everybody's
watching but I don't watch TV okay well
well pretty much at the end of the day
is about a eyes becoming self-aware and
then take over and kill us pretty much
that's gonna happen so Skynet is real
yep we're gonna die like don't be scared
of the crazy guy in the corner of your
street be scared of some robot that's
gonna slice your throat in the middle
night that used to pick up your laundry
so do some survival game now I mean it's
far away yeah look what I don't know is
when it flips but come this is just
kidding
do you know what virtual reality porn
looks like let me save you guys time no
dudes leaving the house in 15 years ever
again we will be a world with no dudes
yeah they're all just gonna be home
porn up and boring boring they already
got the 360 it's way beyond that when
you really play it out when you actually
think it's happening yeah it's over it's
over
yeah they have the the Bluetooth
accessories to go with it now so you
like it's over and so like people be
like that's so weird that's so bad
true go dig up somebody who died in 1854
show them the way we live our lives and
they would think it's the craziest [ __ ]
they've ever seen
yeah the craziest like I have know like
these are people that electric like what
do you think they think like forget
about cable TV or inter no they didn't
have electricity like they didn't even
know what a phone was like they wanted
to do something they like walk 30 miles
or like jump on a [ __ ] horse like
like you know like so yes that's what
happens but we need to figure out as
businessmen as entrepreneurs as human
beings what are we actually gonna see
and what aren't we I do think that
happens what I don't know cuz I'm not
educated enough is is that 50 years away
or is that 200 years away is that but
but all the trends point to a very very
very different world IBM Watson is
smarter than you like it's these are
real things just help write lyrics to a
song and it became a pop hit it's nice
of course cuz once and has all the data
to know exactly what we actually react
to so here the last eight thousand hot
songs and Watson says got it got it got
it okay here's a song yeah there was
something that uh somebody I always talk
about EQ like my big advantages
emotional intelligence and the other
thing and somebody send me a tweet or DM
somewhere that showed that computers now
have more EQ than than humans and I'm
like crap there goes my advantage like
technology is gonna keep taking people's
advantages away and so we need to
understand that yeah it's fun when
you're benefiting it's fun when you use
the internet to build the biggest wine
store but then when wine grapes are
being like turned into molecules and
people just like a stamp and it's like
drinking wine and I'm like you know like
it's always fun when you're on the right
side of this it's not fun when you're on
the other side my big point of view to
everybody who's listening and watching
is figure out how to be on the right
side of it stay woke oh that's such a
yes oh that's it so 2017
what are you focused on what's garyvee
personally focused on we talked a lot
about trends listening to people this is
gonna air you're gonna tell me and I'm
gonna watch everybody's reaction
what part did they like oh they thought
it was cool and I said Twitter was
[ __ ] chicks in the summer good I may
use that again oh they thought like why
did I wear a suit that looks [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I'll never wear a suit like like
I'm a counter-puncher what am I gonna do
in 2017 the same thing I did in 2007
1997 and 1987
I'm gonna watch people's reactions you
know I sold a lot of baseball cards I
see your handsome partner Ryan here in
the back right because I would go and
watch how people reacted to other
people's tables and I would say it would
take me three hours to set up my
baseball card table because I figured
out the UI and the UX of my table and
what people were selling and buying
stuff where I didn't even open up shop I
walked the floor of the convention for
four or five hours and I tasted oh
everybody's pumped about the bo Jackson
black and white score card cool I'll
raise the price Oh everybody's selling
the McGwire
you know USA I'm gonna do that oh the
8687 fill your basketball cards keep
going up let me not sell them this
weekend I react I always react and so
what I'll do in 2017 is I'll pay
attention if snapchats really in trouble
they're really in trouble if 15 and 19
and 23 year olds get off they're not
really in trouble if the views that you
lost were from 45 year olds that were
coming on they need to figure that out
but they're not in trouble got it so
what I'm gonna do is one of the reasons
to your point just earlier is that I'm
putting out a lot of content I've even
gone dailyvees now daily right you know
and that's a reaction Casey the best
video blogger in a game good friend of
mine I invest in this company he stops I
start the next day doing daily because I
knew his audience how to find people I
knew a lot of those 15 year old girls
weren't gonna love me that way because
they didn't care about the business but
that's fine but if I took a percentage
of that that was me reacting I didn't
know Casey was gonna retire from
vlogging this year so that's a reaction
to an opportunity and that's the way to
do it
you're doing as you're staying woke and
you're doing you do diligence
I woke for the rest of my life 24/7 365
thanks that's the truth you know want to
talk tech nerd terms you know there's
programs that run in the back of your
computer at all times that's what I do
I'm running in the back of culture 24/7
and what's really cool for me is I'll be
dangerous enough to come here and make
some references that make everybody know
that I know what's going on I can do the
same thing in 800 different little
subcultures this one's a little more fun
for me because it's true you know but
that's what I do
[Music]
thanks for having me listen we can bring
you back anything around this time we're
gonna talk about the same thing we're
gonna see what happened and we're gonna
I know sir Thomas skills to give you
something for 2018 Summer Jam we're
gonna do some really dope
you